you're not dominant i'll slap you now if
you want me
to stop you
would you actually let me slap you
let me see how hot you are guys
slap me
hi i'm sean reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views let you know what i'm
saying it's all good right now charm
aren't ya and i've had some bad dates
how do you think you've done on the date
i don't really give a [__] i'm not gonna
lie about it where are all the decent
men not in my dms that's for sure you
get me i feel like i'm rolling with
demand then what's going on about your
fives it seems like a lot of men don't
know how to treat a lady i'll just
manhandle everything and this girl's
putting a chest and chest in the nut
like geez
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
moses odie and ldn gang i'm here to give
her the grilling that she normally gives
all the other guys i know she thinks
that she's got all of the vibe but it's
all on me in it so you want a
relationship
with her
[Applause]
she's probably gonna ask me if i give
ahead like this probably going to ask
that and i thought that could have that
question is so sensitive but this is
what i do in it so i'm not having
something like this unless unless she
comes out and she's more pretty than i
thought she would be because i've seen
i've seen on on you know youtube and i
was like she's cute but she's more
pretty in person then i might crumble a
bit but nothing major in it of course
i'm ready why are we still here i don't
know why you guys got me behind this bar
like i'm ready let's let me talk to this
girl let's let's do this man let's go
come on
you're right hello
you okay i'm good steve i'm good thank
you what's your name moses rosie it's
nice to meet you
what's your name cheyenne nice to meet
you to you where are you from
london
leicester
nigeria everywhere everywhere where are
you from um i live essex and my family
in the caribbean i feel like you're a
bit shy right now i don't know why you
think i'm shy no i'm good i'm good you
give him a bit of shy vibes i don't know
whatever she thinks i'm about to do with
her but the way she's giving me the
looks like she can't even look at my
eyes i'm trying
he's the shy one
i think you're giving me shy vibes wow i
don't know just where you come in your
energy is very like that's how i am i'm
just calm just chill tell me a bit about
you i'm a business owner got a few
businesses i'm a youtuber or model
there's a lot of things isn't he what's
all this about like what are you doing
house i'm just trying to find a man that
i can take seriously i don't feel like
you're trying to find a man you can take
serious though like why how long you've
been single for for a few years
what's a few years like three years
you've been single for three years yeah
so
do you think it's your fault or the guys
no it's not anyone's fault it's just by
choice
what kind of choice that's got nothing
to do with me in it if you're single for
three years the issue is clearly you not
me it's not something with the guys it's
all you still
mine i'm big on doing personal
development and working on myself so you
know people preach about being a good
woman but you have to internally do the
work how long is that gonna take though
well it took me four years but it's
still going on so it can be four five
years six years yeah well three year
single okay are you ready to be in a
relationship yeah that's why i'm doing
grinning so you're looking for husband
right now yeah
why are you laughing i don't know if i
tell you i'm going to marry you right
now what are you saying are you going to
get married no why why do i marry you
right now because this is what we're
here for yeah i'm here for marriage with
the right man yeah how do you know i'm
not the right man i don't know your
attitude's a bit
how actually this card yeah it's calm
but it's even a bit sure yourself i'm
just saying if you're looking for love
then i can give you that i can give that
to you you can give me love yes you sure
what else you want stability loyalty
honesty
can you tick those boxes i can take a
lot more than that really what can you
take so many other things but i just
feel like you just stay in the basic
things it seems a bit full of it you're
not going to find your husband like that
i mean you're not those are things that
orgasms just say they have a lot of guys
have stability a lot of guys claim they
love you even though they're not yeah
exactly this is this is the problem a
lot of people are talkers actions aren't
always congruent with what you're what
you say you are so you like actions
yeah
what kind of actions do you like
people just honoring their words okay so
not that not any other type of actions
like what i don't know i just i just go
on as we have actually remind you what
do you mean by actions you said you like
actions are not words my love language
is just fault not physical touch yeah oh
you like physical touch yeah oh so you
do that kind of action yeah but not sex
i think he said no one says sex i didn't
even say tell me about your sex life
great it's fantastic um but everyone
says their sex life is great fantastic
but i thought that man's actually
alright why is it all right i get the
job done what do you mean you get the
job done sex is a mission at the end of
the day you begin it and you end it
i start the mission well and i complete
admission completely so i get the job
done so you're saying women is like just
a task no one said that
you're saying it's a mission
mission it's a really weird way to talk
about sex sex itself not women sex
itself is submission so do you have
meaningless sex no i don't know if the
way you've like said it's a mission i've
had me in their sex though you have yeah
all the time have you not no i can't do
me in the sex you probably had though
before no no i really can't do it what's
your body count my body count
only me and you here so i couldn't be
asking anyone else i'm not going to tell
you
why
it's not reading there i might tell you
in a bit when a girl doesn't give you a
body account her body count is high
forget about it as soon as they tell you
i don't want to tell you their body
count is high i know i already know for
a fact i've already come from something
around like
42 43 44 and four girl sorry that's high
what's your body count
if you didn't tell me what makes you
feel i'm gonna tell you what you might
lead by example no i don't want to you
couldn't find yours anyways judging by
you not telling me your answer i feel
like your body counts probably something
high in it like high what's higher
probably like 14
14 is high i think calling is a good
number yeah no no it is because it
depends on who you are in it some people
some people 14 is really high some
people 14 is low so you've slept with 14
people it's less it's close though 13.
you can keep guessing in it i'm not
going to say it why it's very close it's
not it's nothing crazy in it but i don't
know what crazy is i feel like for a guy
crazy is a buffet but i'm not at that
level still like i said my sexes they
mean a lot no but it's not a mission you
can't take missions it's a mission let
me tell you the mission here
when you have sex is there not an
outcome yeah that's the end of the
mission when you get the outcome you're
not done yeah but you can't mission just
sounds so like
it's just a term i'm giving it you get
what i mean you don't need to listen you
don't need to be perfect with me here
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna judge you in
it it's a mission you ain't completing
this mission mate so do you enjoy your
mission yeah i love it still what do you
love about it it makes me feel like a
man especially when i finish the mission
which is the most important part i just
feel like i've accomplished something
that day would you say you come quick do
you mean do i finish the mission quickly
it depends it depends on the mood if i'm
not feeling it then um
i guess it can be a quick thing but i
just don't do that
why do i not do it if you're not feeling
no i mean like if it's not if i'm not
excited about it do you do full play
yeah that's to get in the mood right
sometimes you can naturally be in the
mood from as soon as you enter remove
all these cameras and and lights if i
just saw you here i'll probably be in
the mood naturally
yeah what do you mean it's a guy thing
in it well i don't know i'm not a guy so
explain as a guy sometimes you see a
girl and immediately you're like yeah
i'd give it to her
like i i
lay on her so if we were to go straight
to the better right now i don't need to
think about giving it to you because i
already thought about it anyways but
sometimes you need to get to that move
like you said you do foreplay at times
which means you've had horrible sex by
the way because you have what you mean
horrible sex firstly like foreplay is so
important to be intimate with someone
you can't just like put your dick in
like a dry vagina why
why why can't you just do that what do
you mean why can't you just do that why
can't you just get straight into it
right i don't know if you're being
serious or not i'm being serious so you
think that you can just
have sex just straight off the back put
your dick inside something i think yeah
i think here that i can have i can text
a girl we can have dirty text we can
link up from as soon as i open that door
into the bedroom we're both ready to
have sex i think that's possible it
happens maybe it's a it's a young wild
thing um you know i'm not calling you
old or anything but it happens like i
feel like people that get into the whole
foreplay and having to bring out the
sexual side you're just you're you're
bringing it out you're dragging it out
no i just feel like from that that just
means you have no game you don't know
how to actually start
it's like how to touch and deal with a
woman
he has
no game she's trying to get the grilling
out of me relax i'm the one doing the
grilling here today it's not your show
anymore it's mine she's doing too much
trying to get onto me trying to ask me
questions make me start it's not
happening today it's all me i'm in
control i'm dominant guy today leave it
out darling come on
listen you can be a full seeker you can
easily like if it's quick thrill
probably put your dick in if you're both
excited but to think that you can just
have sex so easily without foreplaying
you can do it yeah you can but it's the
way your wording is is if it's just like
oh it's really not important like
there's no one that's
it can sound like i'm singing a song
what i said was you can have sex without
the foreplay yeah what are you doing
yeah well exactly i do it and you don't
do it is it because you don't know how
to it's cause i know how to
have the sex without foreplay there's
ways can you do floor play yeah of
course really of course i've done it's
not i'm not saying i'm not done it i've
had to do it you're going to have to say
because like i said there's times where
you make it sound like a chore you said
it's the choice no just the way you're
saying it like i said
no game sometimes it can be more it can
make it more fun it can make it more
exciting but like i said the outcome is
the outcome you're doing the full play
you're doing the mission just to get the
outcome
i'm trying to say so if there's a
quicker way to get the outcome for both
of us why not because the whole point of
sex is like an intimate thing it's not
about doing it quick it's about doing it
right so you both feel good foreplay
yeah leads to you doing it
right how about you just start from
doing it
what are you confused about no i'm not
confused i just can't believe that's
coming out your mouth
anyway yeah but anyway
do you eat [__] then she's bare in
there in terms of licking girls out
listen if she wants supposed to lick her
out she could just ah it's not a big
deal are you [__] how are you doing
yeah do you [__] do you eat [__] i
mean i'm you're asking me i'm giving you
i'm telling you yes dude i thought i eat
[__]
because you tend you love that question
so much yeah i like asking men that
question yeah well i like asking women
that question do you why'd you like ask
a woman [__] yeah she's [__] she's
[__]
from as soon as i asked her the question
and she was like she's [__] you don't
you don't start on questions like that i
looked at her i was like do you [__]
and she was like yeah
do you know
yes
what was the food
and
do you eat breakfast yes breakfast lunch
and dinner sausage
cheese sausage
yeah ah of course you eat sausage that's
cool as long as you eat sausage when was
the last time you cried i don't remember
you know what you mean like it's that
long it's probably primary school
what yeah i don't know why that's a big
deal i don't know why you're screaming
like i stole your one no because that is
a big deal what do you mean i don't know
why i don't get it why is that a big
deal because i just feel like men you're
so like desensitized to
any sort of emotional feeling i feel
like you can be emotional but you don't
need to cry do you feel emotion yeah
yeah
what do you do like how do you process
being sad
as a man that doesn't cry i think about
what's making me sad
i have time alone i just feel bad or i
just feel like in a certain way but for
the tears to come out of my eyes you
don't understand that requires so much
movements like that's
that's like i don't know it's a lot yeah
but don't you think it's good to do that
because it's a release
no no no of course you need to cry
what the hell is he on about
so then one day like you might just like
hold it in and build up because men's
mental health like is a really serious
issue and i find that because men aren't
you know in tune with their emotions in
that way this is why like the mouse
suicide rate is so high because men
don't know how to process emotions what
are you talking about i should ask them
about questions man leave it out this is
what i'm saying this is what are you
talking about you don't need to crash
for you to not
come on man
it's not come on man that's that's just
too far you don't you've literally
linked crying to suicide yeah because
you have to nip it from the butt like
but if we started early teaching men how
to cry how to cry yeah how you're
teaching men how to cry how to feel
if you feel sad cry it helps crying
doesn't help when you're a little boy
and you fall over i'll say you're
running a race you have a sister you
both fall over it's okay for your sister
to cry but you've got a man up don't cry
do you not think that's going to have an
impact as you grow older in your life
and you're going to carry that with you
it has a it has kind of a positive
impact let me finish positive yeah you
need some time to just take some things
in the chin i feel like when it then
gets to like proper
deep like
issues for example you know you're going
for a heartbreak you don't have to cry
to solve it why do you have to cry i'm
not saying it's going to solve it but
i'm saying like it's concerning when
there's such an emotional block because
heartbreak that's a reason to cry have
you ever had a heartbreak yeah wow so
sorry about that um have you have you
have you ever experienced anything
really have you ever been in love you
think so no so you listen
heartbreak when you're in love
heartbreak is hard you know i don't want
to get into that topic with you because
you might start crying and that might
help you
so when you had a heartbreak did you cry
yeah of course i did how many times did
you cry good for you the first time you
cried it didn't help no it did a good
cry hello you cried again
so it didn't help the first second or
third time it does it helps the way you
feel
not really
as a guy instead of you crying you just
take one in the chin and you move on
with your life
this is what i'm saying it's great that
you think like that but later down the
line there comes to a point
in men's lives when you can't keep
taking it on the chin like that then you
cry then you cry
that's when you cry okay i've never said
you should never cry you asked me about
my cried i said no but you know but i
was just saying yeah yeah eventually you
end up crying didn't it
do you get a lot of women can i ask what
do you think yeah i think you get a lot
of women i don't you don't really why
because i'm very reserved i don't put
myself out there for the woman oh so
you're a woman coming to you no i'm just
not
actively available i feel like i'm too
busy like i've got a lot of things going
on in my life there's a perfect time for
you to find a woman for you to be in
love you get a lot of guys i can tell i
think all women do
men always try their luck that don't
mean all women gets a lot of guys yeah
but we have i think women have the upper
hand like men are always
trying to push you women yeah you're a
lot of the praise and what the predators
do have any fetishes i like my hair
being scratched nothing weird though
like i'm not really into the toast offs
why would you say it's weird
because it
you're too fast
yeah no but it's not even that like it's
not weird it's just what people like
socks online wear your shoes or just
wear your heels why must the toes be
touched and me personally i feel like
the toes it's probably one of the
deadest part of the body do you like
that sucking your tails i like a foot
massage
do you like guys sucking your toes would
you like me to soak your thoughts no i
like massages so you don't want you
don't want to suck your taste
i don't know it depends i guess i could
say if you want bring them outside them
bring it out i'm open to experiment and
try new things are you yeah that's one
thing about me so even if i tell you i
don't like sound like that you can
probably convince me to try so you're
adventurous
yeah my sister real name literally moses
my god moses the ldn was just added
because you know from london in it but
um yeah i'm not one of those guys that
changes their name to you know
kills or reeks or there's just moses in
it that's my god geranium red flags i
always have the last word so you're
argumentative i'm not argumentative but
i'll have the last word it's your petty
petty yeah yeah but would you would you
rather me lie to you no petty no i want
a man not on this childish games i don't
like a woman that jumps to conclusion i
hate that so much like i've just told
you what's happened and you've linked it
to doing something else i don't like
that would you say you're an honest man
yeah i'm very honest i don't really beat
around the bush as a person i'm very
patent what makes you a patented guy i
feel like i've got a lot of things in
place i've got a good business around me
i've got good friends around me a good
family around me i'm very focused i'm
not out here in the streets doing
rubbish i know what i want
my goals and plans are set and i am
reaching towards that and what happened
like i'm trying to say like i'm not
i can't tell you defects because i know
for a fact i'm working towards what i
need to get so that's why i'm very much
behind nice what do you want
um you
all right okay a few little giggles
there he's a bit funny that's funny
what do you want i want you do you yeah
can i have you
oh that's your last name my loss why is
it my loss because you're gonna end up
getting a guy that's not patterned just
like you i'm a very focused person
i know what i want and i know what i
need to do to get it so i'm not going to
end up with just some waste man
somewhere eastman didn't say he was a
waste man that's your words not mine i'm
not saying
why why don't i want you yeah why
not finding it at the moment am i not
your type i don't really have a type so
why don't you on paper you probably
would be well put it on paper then
put it on paper you're laughing you're
smiling you're grinning like what's
what's wrong
do you like i'm just waiting for the
little vibe the vibe is dead i just made
you laugh like no you can't just make
someone laugh when they think that's a
vibe can you dance yeah can you do salsa
i've never tried salsa you know
can you yeah you want to try right now
define love
love is when you're willing to die for
someone yeah
that for you that for me
what if i'm a [__] then i still dabble
i die for a [__] when did you last have
sex look at me when you say it i'm
feeling like i'm nothing
it has sex three days ago was it
meaningless or was it no it was
meaningful did she enjoy herself yeah
who comes first even if it's me she
still comes it doesn't really matter
are you sure
as long as you get the job done do you
want to apply for the job i got a few
vacancies here if you want do i want to
apply for the job yeah i don't know
maybe you want a job in it come work for
me man you need the job well actually
doesn't want to work here it's a big
opportunity man i can't make the money i
will not be applying for the job don't
you worry for you i can make you manage
your [__] away when was the last time
you had sex you're not gonna tell me are
you no it was a very long time ago
two weeks no like months probably six do
you miss it
no i'm at this stage where because i've
not been
doing it i'm over it didn't think about
it no i'm doing this year no sex this
whole year yeah 2022.
even if this date goes well yeah it
can't happen what's your name because
how long time sex sex is really
important to you it's not really
important but it's it's needed yeah of
course it's needed but do you want to
have sex like it's not that i don't i
find men are quite a distraction come on
what does she mean she doesn't want to
have sex i'll be honest she doesn't want
to have sex she's just acting up
why now i just feel like i'm not feeling
it anymore you gotta give ahead like
come on man that's just that's whack i
can't i can't speak to a guy that's not
willing to give head especially if you
want me to be giving you come on
that's perfect
why why are you not giving ahead you
want to have great sex yeah you claim
what's the voice you need to have four
players
but you don't want to give head head is
part of full play all right it's a yeah
but only if you're my mom i am your man
you're trying to be my man i'm worried
your men oh is that sorry he's letting
you process it okay
okay i fancy him a little bit
are you
what do you do to be so dominant first
of all we both can't be dominant all
right so pick up know then no no you you
stop it
99.9 of girls their favorite position is
missionary
is that yours
yes well then what are you talking about
how are you doing in bed i'm on top
of missionary yeah then that's the thing
is there it is no it's not this is what
have you been watching but i've caused
the same isn't it no no are you giving
me streaks on top yeah that's missionary
no darling no no let me do the job you
just lay down there and act cute i did
the mission you did it eerie simple done
missionary is a guy on top giving
strokes that's it full stop oh do not
think i am do you do the choking do you
do the slapping i'll slap you i'll
provide like you if you want do we do a
little battle with the dominance
there's no it's not a battle i really
want i will slap you if you want dad i
don't want you to slap me you should
want to slap me if you're dominant he
actually wants me to slap him you're not
dominant i'll slap you now if you want
slap me
you're ready to stop you
would you actually let me stop you
let me see how hot you are guys
slap me okay now wash my hands
right can you ring your face
like a little
little one it was all right it wasn't
that sexy though it's supposed to be a
sexy slap no no no this is the thing
when you when you're being dominant
you're not trying to be sexy like
that was you're
dead slap man i felt like a hug like man
yeah no
yeah
you like that that's not
that [__] no
when you're
a submissive man yeah and you're like a
little slave or something yeah
then it's a completely different way
you're not dominant man just leave it
out you don't think i'm jumping i'm not
done with it you are just there saying i
gotta be careful ow that's what you're
doing it's nothing you're not done with
it why don't you strangle me then
yeah come on show me how you would
dominate me and strangle me i'll tell
you if it's like a good strangle
come on this one
it's quite in the right one it's not all
right
even if it was amazing just it was going
to say all right
you're still thinking about it
oh i gotta calm down it's okay calm down
relax i can swing you some more after
that
you got the grab that's what it is it's
i know you're gonna say oh i'd say elsa
should be nice
yeah you're attractive
you wouldn't you know what it's not an
issue if you say yes but me personally i
feel like the exes that i've had i can't
be friends with them
maybe in the future
if i have a good experience i'm going to
say by the exit i've had i can't be
friends with them i've never had a bad
breakup
okay so like we've always been on good
terms and just the way i see life like
it'll be a shame for someone i've shared
just life with for it'd be ashamed to
pass them in the street and have like
bad blood with them okay but it's not
like you're still texting them and
linking up no i'd link up with one of my
exes like every few years like we'll
we'll hang out
but that's it
why are you guys linking up because
we're friends like above it i think
because like people forget before you
get in a relationship usually like your
friends first so just because we didn't
work out on a intimate level doesn't
mean that we should lose out on a
friendship because we're really good
friends
fair enough um
honestly i don't care you know whether
you're friends with your eggs or not as
long as you're with me that's what my
eyes simple
i don't know why you said no but if i
told you my body can was over 100 you
wouldn't be happy okay it would bother
me a little
but it's not going to be an issue
okay but but you do care yeah
no it's only a small amount because i'm
not one of those people where it's like
no it's a red flag for me it would make
me question the answer is yes clearly i
get what you mean though exactly
i get what you're saying but answer's
not a name all right yes then okay fair
enough but yeah like it's like you said
it it can't be extreme it can't be too
much but personally it's not something
that will really bother me um because
everyone has their past at the end of
the day plus a lot of people lie about
their body count anyway so whenever you
tell me it's two or a hundred i would
never know what it is for real so
it will never really get in the way of
me liking someone or being with someone
so i don't really think it's a big deal
but
if i do find out that you know it's over
100 or whatever of course i'm going to
care it's normal in it
not my girl never my girl sleeping with
bear man forget about it it's not
possible
the main reason why i'm a family person
is because i don't really have a lot of
family around me
but i do have a family that do depend on
me even though they're not all around me
i didn't come from a wealthy background
i came from a poor background the
makings that i've made the income that
i've made i feel like the only way i can
give back is to give to my family and
every time i do it it makes me happy
generally that's all that matters to me
if you get what i mean like my family my
loved ones yeah everything else is just
whatever happens happens in it you guys
so that's why i'm so heavy on the family
business and so on and so forth so
you're a provider
yeah
i've never achieved and not that i was
making an assumption but i'm quite
surprised
really yeah
i think you cheated
no listen from the the icons that she's
giving me she's cheated like i can't
really tell like it's just cheating at
least once maybe not physically but i
feel like you cheated um
no no
fair enough i mean this is another one
of the questions where you never knew
the actual answer well i'm funny giving
it to you well you know i don't know the
people you've dated why do i cheat
i'll just leave just leave
no one's ever going to come here and
tell you they've cheated do you get
regardless if they have or not a few
have
really i've never cheated anyways big up
to them a minute i've never really felt
the reason to cheat like you said just
leave and i'm very straightforward like
if i like you
i like you if i'm starting to feel a
certain type of way i'll tell you i feel
like to go ahead and cheat you're
already out of love from the jump from
when you even think about doing a yoda
out of love and i feel like from when
you're out of luck you must have had
some conversations before that if not
then yeah i mean that's just when it's
not correct would you stay with a woman
that cheated i mean it's so easy to say
no
but i feel like if [__] really hit the
fan and it depends on the level like for
example if she was a woman of my kids
especially if i was married and we had
we have businesses together so on and so
forth you know i mean then i can start
saying uh probably yes but as of right
now if you know hell no like go away
there's so many other fishes in the sea
would you ever sleep with a friend's ex
um no no i don't think i would
personally me and my friends are like
brothers in it it depends what kind of
friend they're because you know
sometimes you just make quick friends
that you don't even give a toss about
but not like my close brothers yeah no
nothing like that would you i wouldn't i
wouldn't if it was like my girl
no way
but like you said if it's just someone
that we've met in a club and we've
decided we're friends as women like we
kind of do this [__] blocky thing with
each other where
we'll make friends of you in the toilet
it's like in the club and blah blah
that's my ex-boyfriend and then because
you've just met her and she seems like a
nice person you kind of feel really bad
talking to the guy that's chatting you
up and then you're just like oh sorry do
you go clubbing no
i'm not in that avenue i really don't
care about that um time consuming money
consuming like i said there's always
outcomes everything in your life
guys that go clubbing go clubbing to
spare money and press women take them
home and have sex yeah to do the mission
anyways um
yeah
i don't really understand because i
don't i don't think every girl goes
clubbing for the exact same mission no
like do you not just go out to have a
good time with your mates yeah but it
doesn't have to be clubbing we can do so
many more jeremy there's so many
different things especially my friends
we love traveling that's one thing we
love doing um and when you think about
the money you're going to spend in the
club compared to how much you spend on
travelling it's probably roughly the
same anyway so i believe the country
though why am i still here when i am
abroad i will go to a few clubs just to
have fun but my main thing is just
exploring and just seeing things i've
never seen before i'm a weirdo if you
can say i'm a weirdo i guess but because
i know a lot of people tend to go
clubbing but that's not really me in it
no it's good
i'd let you buy me a drink in a bar
what would you do if i wanted to start
an only fans sell your clothes or to
sell to
pictures
organic pictures
it depends how you want to use it if you
want to use it in a very sexual way
that's your choice that i'm not involved
in that's all you and it you get at that
point you're doing porn
you get whatever's not only fans on
pornhub it's porn but if you're out here
showing your toes and doing lingerie
pictures that's what people do on
instagram anyways even if you're there
to sell your socks never don't even
download the app better than a buyable
app or go download ebay or something go
buy us on some jewelry live man not
doing that over here forget about it
what's your thoughts on women that work
in the adult industry pick them up
because there's times where you need
them
[Applause]
no that's real they're they're doing
it's a service i may not need them to
them it's a hustle but to other people
to service do you get a supply and
demand business so i don't really think
there's anything wrong with it that's
what you want to do that's when i'm
doing it what about if i didn't want to
sleep with you for the first six months
six months was a bit too long i'll
probably try to
show you why you should
follow we'll have a bit of dry sex
sessions anyways i think the issues with
me if you don't want to do it i wouldn't
think it's with you even though you tell
me i'm just focusing on myself and so i
still think it was with me but i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna force you i mean if
you don't wanna do you don't wanna do it
like for me as a woman
i would like to know that there's a man
that's willing to wait i think it says
more about the man okay like that's
gonna wait around and get to know you on
a level instead of just like sleep with
you straight away yeah but six months is
a bit of a stretcher don't you think no
for guys willing to wait two months
that's a long time taking your eyes
looking after you two months i think
that's all right to notice that he's
willing to wait yeah yeah i mean i don't
think you have to go six months plus if
the girl doesn't want to do anything
within six months that's a bit worrying
for the guy like you know i could be
working on myself tina's working on
myself business yeah yeah
let's leave it yeah let's
because what you what what's the job
what is it what what what is it girl
stop saying that it's a lie it's a joke
you're just finding a reason to not chat
to guys you're not working yourself i'm
tired of hearing this man please
leave it just internal work you're okay
you're fine you're not working on
yourself you're good you're looking for
love you're pretty you have you have
your business and whatever you got going
on you're fine what are you working on
so a lot of girls just say that as an
excuse i'm working on myself no you're
not you're fine you're good man
what did you do if i wanted to involve
other people in our sex life is it two
girls could be
then you know
let's get cracking could you handle two
women
um yeah but not the first round
what if i was in a gang
are you killing who you shooting why
can't you take me seriously because what
gang are you in let's imagine you wasn't
a gang i don't know i can't do it
because i'm not i'm not gm myself i'm
not gang member
gang life from when me i ain't even
about that why are you about that listen
if you're on that leave me out of it i'm
not involved i'm more about that life at
all did you get like i'm really really
away from that life i like peace harmony
i don't want to be looking at my back
when i'm you know so i can't no it can't
work how about if i wasn't a gang
no i'm not about that life but i thought
i felt like girls loved that no
when you're a teenager you think it's
cool yeah when you get older then as you
get older you realize it's not about
that life it's about a good man with
good morals and stability not saying
these men aren't lifestyle that i'm not
really interested in but you do want a
guy that can put you in a place now
let's be put in my place do you think
there's an element of of a bad man
though no not not physically a bad
person no a really a really good
hard-working man
that has a legit job can easily put me
in one place
so we had a good day
yeah i have actually would you tell them
the best day you've been on no
has any other guys choked to you no
why'd you let me choke you yeah i wanted
to see that kind of gave me a bit of a
green light which mean i don't know i
just feel like that's a bit wilder like
you wanted one to try it how do you
think you've done on the date i think
i've done right i feel like i got to
know you a bit more i feel like you're
not as
confident as i thought you were but you
are no not in a negative way i thought
you was going to be very
um like on to me
well you're you're cute like you're
you're innocent and
i mean you give a lot of shy vibes which
is cute and i'm you know i'm happy i
made you laugh a few times and smile or
whatever what do you rate yourself out
of 10 on this date
i give myself an eight i'm humble hey
it's humble i thought it's really high
ten is really high i feel like i made
you laugh i feel like we had an
interesting chat you know we touched on
the sex part
i think eight eight is all right
oh my god the date actually went really
well you know what
i actually enjoyed myself i didn't think
i was going to enjoy myself it was
purely vibes
listen the beginning was a no-go i was
not feeling it she's a very pretty girl
she let me choke her which is obviously
going to need some more don't worry i'll
let you guys know when it happens i like
him it could be the wine though lord
knows what would happen if she finished
her wine no he handled it well stayed
calm and collected there was no grill in
there man there was probably a micro
even but there was no there was no
grilling there was nothing being grilled
i would see him again would you see her
again yeah yeah but we'll never be
anything seriously that's for real i'll
definitely see her again yeah he's
attractive but there was a lot of red
flags in the beginning knowing how she
is probably give me a
seven
or six if she gives me a lower than a
six sorry more scrapping
i'm going to give him a 6.8
i'm going to give him that because i
feel like i'm attracted to him but you
need to have a little bit more for me to
actually give you a good rating
you